[Music]
hey everybody
happy labor day yep
i'm really really sleepy
i went out last night yeah
so we got to talk about this movie that
we saw the other day this is uh fire in
the sky from 1993.
yeah travis walton case
i remember when this movie came out
everybody uh really liked it i saw it
and really didn't see much in it at the
time i just quickly kind of forgot about
it
but i remember everybody talking about
it for a long period of time yes movie
going back and seeing it again
knowing the case now
better than i did it is a pretty good
movie uh
i enjoyed it it's the [ __ ] all-star
cast
um
there's a lot of differences between
travis walton's story about what
happened when he got inside the damn
flying saucer
but the rest of it kind of sticks in
general to what to what these what the
rest of the loggers said
the rest of the witnesses will you know
they claim they see it
um i enjoyed it what do you think yeah i
kind of feel like um
this is a movie i'm pretty sure
i see that's the thing i thought i
watched it like when we were gonna do a
show about travis walton like about that
case um and i've and i'd seen like parts
of it but i don't know if i'd ever like
sat and watched the whole thing straight
through so this might have been like the
first time that i actually watched the
whole thing it's actually a pretty good
movie it's um
it's largely it's not really i don't
even know if i'd call it a sci-fi movie
even though it's about an alien
abduction it's kind of more of a drama
yeah um like a character drama which
actually i think is really good because
i really like uh like you said i've
forgotten how star studded this cast is
yeah it's got the dude from terminator
2. yeah the t-1000 yeah
he's got the [ __ ] rock dude from the
rockford files yeah james garner's in it
uh craig sheffer is in it he was in like
a ton of [ __ ] uh henry thomas is in it
um d.b sweeney plays um travis uh walton
and he's uh he's great actually honestly
i think that uh that's good robert
patrick like you know the t-1000 oh yeah
the poor guy he's going to be known as
the t-1000 like for his whole entire
life even though he was in other [ __ ]
he's great in this yeah the acting's
good
um i think he's like really a highlight
because you know everybody got used to
seeing it was like the t-1000 so it's
like he's sort of like playing a you
know cyborg or whatever but
he's actually really really good in this
all practical effects the effects are
kind of they're good for the time you
know uh they're kind of cool to see now
uh my big problem with the movie is how
much they changed travis's description
of what went on inside the [ __ ] flats
off i think it was because at least
according to the wikipedia page it was
because they thought that what actually
happened was too boring
so they had to like make it now i will
say that the the whole scene of him like
inside the spaceship like with the
aliens doing the weird [ __ ] to him is
like actually pretty scary um and i
think it's actually like a really good i
think
the thing about it is that i think
whenever anybody talks about this movie
that's like the only scene that they
remember because that's a pretty big i
mean and it's industrial light and magic
did the special effects on it like i
said they're all you know they're all
practical effects obviously because it's
in 1993. um and that part is pretty cool
like it's pretty cool and creepy and
stuff but it's like nothing like what he
said really happened i like travis's
version of it better
yeah yeah
he said it was just kind of a cold
sterile interior
um actually i said cold stare it's just
a sterile [ __ ] mechanical interior
like a hospital room
bending corridors
um
he saw
basically great a couple of grays
but then after that he saw nothing but
human beings
and i think in spacesuits or flight
suits
yeah and uh
things that were kind of a cross between
a human being and the alien
and
uh then they
took him to an open hangar had little
flat saucers in it so he was in some
kind of mothership
and then uh he couldn't really remember
so he was kind of like in a dream like
state he saw the control room that had
all kinds of stars and they would all
converge down into one and then go back
it was like a holographic display
um
i liked his version of it better he said
it was hot and humid in there so they
must have been from florida these areas
yeah
so that was the only thing it was
florida aliens it was real hot and humid
in there but it wasn't it's not what
they showed in the movie they they
definitely ripped off [ __ ] hr giger
[ __ ] alien from alien 1 and alien 2
where it's kind of
slimy honeycomb with hives and
puts you in little womb compartments
and everything is all gloopy yeah with
dead people in them and stuff it was it
was pretty lurid you know
and it was kind of you could tell they
were trying to
trying to piggyback this case on the
back of the [ __ ] alien wanted too
you know which i thought was a cheap
shot
um
the aliens themselves looks pretty good
i actually like the look of the aliens
they were orange though i well i like
that they do like they kind of tip the
hat to like you know the grays like with
the big eyes and everything but then it
turns out that those are like little
spacesuits you know what i mean remember
he finds that little spacesuit yeah and
it's like so the actual aliens don't
really look like that that's just their
little outfit yeah which i thought that
was pretty cute no i was trying to
determine though like you know the
famous abduction scene where he's in
there and they put like the weird sheet
and like kind of water board or more
which they're not waterboarding him but
it's like kind of like that
plastic thing that holds him down and
like then they cut it open and like put
the gloopy [ __ ] in his mouth and like
put the thing down and then stick thing
in his eyeball and then i'm wondering
because the whole time i'm watching this
i'm like that's pretty creepy and like
that'd be really horrifying if that
actually did happen to you
but what exactly were the aliens doing
like i couldn't figure out they were
[ __ ] messing with [ __ ] molesting
his wee-wee
they were sounding him or something
there he went out of his belly button
with something i don't know they were
just did something they did penetrated
that man they did something like that
you know something unspeakable
they're just doing it for shits and
giggles maybe they weren't even like
doing any scientific experience
experiments they're just like freaky
like molesters fetishists
that's what that's that's what the
aliens are that's like those are the
ones that come here they have like a
weird like fetish for humans and they
just like do they're so they're not like
trying to do anything like constructive
they just like sticking yeah sticking
things up people's butts the problem
it's a good movie the problem with the
case is that when travis was found what
was it five days later i think it was
five days yeah he couldn't remember what
happened
yeah so the whole story about what
happened inside the this flying saucer
that was a recovered memory
when they were they had they put him in
a damn
trance
and then he remembered it then
well [ __ ]
that's real uh
that's gotta there there's
that's how they found out that satanists
could flush little children down toilets
into secret rooms where chuck norris
lived
and then satanists could escape from the
police on a [ __ ] hot air balloon what
that's totally true
so
you know
travis's
story his his memory of what had
happened would not be reliable
recovered memories just be as pronounced
says okay travis show us on the doll
where the alien is
right
where the aliens text you
i'm wondering though here's um a lot of
people actually really do seem to like
this movie and like i said the acting in
it is great i honestly really like all
the character stuff like but you know
particularly like the friendship between
uh travis and mike uh which i think is
kind of like the heart of the movie
um and but
one criticism that a lot of people had
um was that they didn't like that so
much of the first part of the movie was
kind of concerned with
you know the mystery aspect of like you
know where is travis and where's because
it's like they're like people that would
be going to see this movie
would already know
um you know that his friends didn't kill
him they would know you know they would
know that he was gonna come back that
he'd been abducted by aliens so some
people like so so it just takes too long
like this mystery aspect like you're
wondering it's like we know what
happened you know just get to get to
that part um but i actually didn't
really mind that but that was just
something that um a lot of reviews i
read a lot of people didn't like the way
that it was structured
um
well i had to keep you in suspense for a
lot of the movies so that's that's how
they did it yeah
the way they described
the flying saucer itself is very
different from how it was shown in the
movie it was just like a dark flying
saucer like some other alien you know
uh but that's not how they described it
the witnesses described it as like a
brand new shiny corvette it's just not
you know a bunch of lights and
big panels with lit up panels and
real pretty looking that's how that's
how they said it looked
it
it's a it's a fun movie to watch
yeah i quite liked it it doesn't it
doesn't match the tail no not not you
know certain aspects of it didn't match
the tale but they're taking liberties i
don't think travis walton and his
buddies liked this movie too much
well i saw like um a little bit it was
from several years ago but i saw um
an interview with him that was like 15
minutes long or something
and uh they were asking him like what
the differences were he didn't say that
he didn't like the movie but he just
said um you know it's they changed a lot
of [ __ ] honestly he said
that when they actually went out into
the woods that there was seven of them
not five of them like they show in the
movie um he's like the the stuff about
uh he's like actually it wasn't just
like one cop working on the case like
you know james garner uh you know the
rockford files um working on it he's
like it was a bunch of people um he's
like it wasn't the whole town turning
against them like thinking that they
murdered the guy and everything he's
like that wasn't as pronounced um and he
said yeah the stuff on the ship was like
nothing nothing like that
but like i said they you know he i think
they knew going in because like the
producers were kind of like hey like
whatever he said this like sounds kind
of boring so we need to make it like
scarier
um which it was like i said that scene
is like actually really effective i
really like you know when he comes out
of the womb thing and he's like floating
around in zero gravity and stuff that
was actually pretty cool i like that
scene but that's like nothing like he
described yeah i would have i liked his
version of the story in case you guys
don't know
how how the story goes is they were out
they were out of truck cutting down
trees they were all lumberjacks yeah
they're loggers loggers this was in
arizona in the 70s 1975. and uh it was
getting late
and they were trying to drive back to
the main roads and they saw a light come
over the horizon looked like a forest
fire and then
uh
what it really was is it was a flying
saucer that had what was coming and it
[ __ ] came and looked at the car
and everybody was tripping out on it and
travis is dumb ass jumps out and starts
running towards the flying saucer waving
his arms you know
hey take me with you and evidently a
beam of light or
or an arc like i think they said an
electrical arc [ __ ] jumped out of it
and hit travis and blew him up in the
air like he [ __ ] like a damn grenade
went off
and these guys in the truck got scared
and [ __ ] bolted boom they ran down
the road and then once they got uh
one once the the fear subsided they
turned around to go see what happened to
travis and when they got back the flying
saucer was gone so was
travis seven days later travis is
[ __ ] calling him from down pay phone
and he he can't remember where he was
all right now
travis travis then goes underneath the
damn hypnosis and gives all these
[ __ ] recovered memories that
ufologists get their hands on travis see
the big problem which they kind of show
in the movie they kind of show like two
very uh aggressive ufo people like
coming in there like what was it what
did it look like what did the aliens
look like and they're like sticking
microphones in his face and stuff from
what i remember of his tale i hadn't
heard him tell a story in a long time
he just says what happened and then i
met
i put two and two together or you know i
interpreted what he said
um as this he was laying
he was laying on a damn operating table
and he opened his eyes he came he came
to and they had some kind of a machine
on him that somehow fixed him and he
knocked it off and got up off the table
the door opened and an alien walked in
and he saw it it looked like a damn bug
he basically describes a gray
and then he throws something out and he
kind of like attacks it and threatens it
and it runs away
and then um he runs out of the room and
goes into another room and finds a chair
and had all these damn holograms of
holograms of stars
and he and on the arm rest of one of the
chairs there was some kind of control
there like a joystick and
he started hitting it and all the stars
were moving and converging into one
and he said [ __ ] it i got to get out of
the ship and he [ __ ]
runs out and goes down the hallway and
the hallway's curved you know because
he's in like a saucer
and it's curved you can't see very far
around the corner
and um
eventually he runs into a dude i think
is in a space suit
a human in a spacesuit was it captain
kirk no
i said it was like a little human that
didn't speak but he kind of
could understand what it wanted
telepathically it didn't talk to him and
it grabbed him
and took him out of the flat saucer
and the flying saucer was in the damn
hangar bay of the whole bunch of ones a
bunch of other ones so they were working
on him inside the scout ship not on the
mother ship that's kind of that that's
how i interpreted it maybe he wasn't in
in a little flying saucer just thought
he was it's been been a while since i've
heard it
and uh
you saw the other little flying saucer
scout ships in the mother ship and they
put him into a room and there was a
bunch of other uh humans in there
humanoids that were in space suits and
they were just they weren't talking to
him they were just looking at him and
that's that's like the last thing he
remembered so
what you can surmise is based on his
story
they accidentally he ran up to the
flying saucer they accidentally killed
him
yeah
an arc of electricity jumps out so they
felt responsible so they beam him aboard
and they bring him back to life but it
takes time maybe five seven days to
bring him back to life
um he attacked him when he saw him so uh
they used my control on him and he saw
all the aliens as human beings after
that but they didn't speak but he could
kind of understand him telepathically
and then they calmed his ass down and
evidently knocked him back out and then
just dropped him off dropped him off at
the gas station
drop that [ __ ] off with a gas station
with some coins in his pocket
so he can make a call although in the
movie he was naked yeah so where did he
so where did he get the coins from
that's not how you know that's not how i
have well remember he was calling trying
to call collect oh that's right yeah
you're trying to call cool you're right
you're right
they wouldn't answer that okay see this
screenwriter's smarter than i am i guess
yeah
if i remember correctly he was not naked
in in the original story i didn't think
he was either but like i said it seemed
like like i said you know they do this a
lot with you know quote unquote based on
a true story type of stuff like i said i
don't know if this is a true story or
not but um you know they always got to
make it like sexier for the for the
movie so people will go see the movie uh
but yeah he was like all they did say
now did they not say like it was five
days right he was gone for five days or
seven i think something like that i
can't remember now when they found him
though like didn't they say he was like
super dehydrated and
stuff like that that's what they said in
the movie but i don't know if they if
they actually
uh say and i don't know if that's actual
part of the case
yeah in the movie they said that but
yeah
i don't know like he hadn't drank
anything for i don't know if there's
evidence of that from the actual case
yeah i'm not sure either
it would and then later on they uh give
him some
while travis was gone they were they
gave some um lie detector tests to the
to the other guys
they were
they wanted to they wanted to see
whether they killed those dude if they
killed him or not but they passed him
they passed the lie detector test
evidently
that they had that he you know that he
got hurt by a flying saucer and
disappeared
they believed it
evidently now
can you uh
can you fool a lie detector yeah
evidently you can
i don't know how to do it but
they say it's possible could all five of
them guys do it i don't know
they say the guy who gave the test was
reliable but we i don't know that either
i wasn't there i don't know who that guy
is now let's just speculate if this if
this story is not true
um
what do you think
they saw or i mean if they were actually
like telling the truth after what they
saw what do you think they saw if it
wasn't an alien spacecraft yeah i think
that'd be the only option you think yeah
you don't think it was just some kind of
weird like maybe it was a fire or like
some kind of weird electrical storm
travis's body was gone
that's true it took him
and uh he said that
based on based on the story that he
tells
they brought him back to life
hmm
using some technology which i don't see
that as being impossible
yeah probably not i think we can kind of
do that now
depending on how long you've been dead
and what was wrong with you
turns out he was only mostly dead yeah
um
why i don't know i [ __ ] are there was
a damn japanese girl this is a couple
years back
she had
poisoned herself or tried to commit
suicide and was out in the damn freezing
cold and laid out there for
24 hours
well cold that'll uh that'll preserve
you yeah but she was dead she was dead
as [ __ ]
and then they brought her back uh they
took her to the hospital and just for
shits and giggles they put her on a
ventilator
just for [ __ ]
yeah
let's see this probably isn't going to
do anything let's just do it anyway she
was dead they put her on
from when i remember correctly they put
her on a ventilator and just kept her
cold
and uh she was there for like another
[ __ ] seven or eight hours and slowly
she kind of came back too
and she was dead they did this just by
[ __ ] blowing
air through her lungs
if my if my memory is correct i'll have
to look i think they did some other
stuff too or they were injecting some
drugs into her
can you imagine it's like they just
they thought she was dead the whole time
and then like the doctor walks in the
room and she's sitting up you probably
[ __ ] a brick it was some kind of an
experiment
but you know they found it she she yeah
she fit the the criteria of what the
experiment was looking for
so they just put her dead ass up on
there and [ __ ]
shot her up fully [ __ ] drugs probably
amphetamines
and uh just ventilated her and it took a
long time but she
came back to life was she okay after she
didn't have brain damage or anything
definitely not
weird like i said i have heard of people
like um i remember hearing one case i
think it was maybe it was a kid and they
um had drowned in like some really
really cold water yeah and they were
under there for like a really long time
and they were dead and then but they
were able to bring them back and they
didn't have any uh but usually it has to
be like super super cold yeah you know
well she wasn't frozen solid but they
said damn near
now i've seen a video of some of a woman
found a [ __ ] kitten just frozen to
like frozen solid like a rock
and she brought that kitten into the
house and brought it back to life
i saw that video that was some weird
[ __ ] that was crazy she just tried to
bring it back to life you think that
little poor little kitty would have got
like freezer burners yeah the cat
[ __ ] came back to life and it was all
right it's on youtube
yeah that's where i saw it i just
happened to see that because it's like
because i wanted it
frozen sit stiff as a board yeah i don't
think it was her cat either
no i think they just found it they found
it in the snow yeah yeah i remember that
she said let's see if i can revive this
i don't remember how she did it did she
put it in warm water
um i don't remember if they put in warm
water they just i think they had the
fireplace going they just kind of like
they isn't they just kind of like rubbed
their towels and yeah
massaging like you know thought thawed
the little kitty back outside they
brought that japanese girl
back to life and she uh
she'd been dead for a [ __ ] long time
she'd you know what i mean
and she wasn't frozen solid but damn
near
that'd be really freaky yeah
did they ask her about anything it's
like hey where are you were you in i
don't think she remembered anything
i mean i i would think that probably
yeah that would be like a really really
weird thing i remember exactly you guys
can look it up and it's been a while
since i've heard about the case and i
think somebody told me about it
so i don't remember if i actually
researched that myself these somebody
just told me about it
see i may be wrong so you think that
maybe that's what happened to travis
that like the aliens accidentally i
think they killed him killed him yeah
and then he could put him back like they
hit the wrong button and they was like
oh [ __ ] who knows
instead of a goddammit car i remember
correctly
see in the movie they showed a beam of
light hitting him yeah all right but if
i remember correctly he said that it was
uh everybody else said it was like more
like an
arc of electric
electricity jumped out and hit him like
a lightning bolt
and blew him up into the air like a
grenade
and then he hit the way he hit they said
oh he's dead
yeah and then they take off because he
hit like a ragdoll which they did show
in the movie but another thing that uh
travis said too was that he's like in
the movie they show them like all
freaking out and like driving off which
they did um but then in the movie mike
says no we have to go back but all the
other guys get out of the truck and
travis was like that's not we all went
back it's like it wasn't just it wasn't
just mike see you could bring somebody
back to life when you think about it if
you had
like star trek
transporter technology
yeah i mean
you could uh dissolve that person
in into just their [ __ ]
molecules
and then using the computer program
replace all the damaged parts
okay
with
what your data files say the organs
should look like
and then just [ __ ]
re-molecularize
molecular remolecular
you get old you can't pronounce it
and then he comes back as a whole body
all right now it would be dead but then
you revive that you got all the you got
all the [ __ ] biomechanics necessary
to start respiration and circulation and
you know what i mean like you're not
going to revive a dude who's [ __ ]
yeah i mean applesauce gonna have to
have him [ __ ] together you know
applesauce yeah
he's just looking you're pouring him out
like that you know yeah we'll bring you
back you know you can't do that
sorry yeah i just thought of a
a line from a mystery science theater
short can you identify this bucket full
of your brother yeah
because he got hit by a train that has
the structure has to be sound you know
and that's why you know zombies don't
really make sense because they're rotten
the structure isn't sound see that right
there is this giant plot hole right so
so i can kind of i can kind of imagine
that aliens might be able to fix a body
at the [ __ ] molecular level
yeah maybe so just almost kind of like a
3d printing you should do it with
[ __ ] i like it like a transporter
technology or something like that you
know put them back together
and you and you now you have a good
fresh dead body then you revive that
nice fresh dead body yeah well maybe he
had rotten a little bit from a couple of
hours or maybe a couple of days but
there might be enough data to go no we
can put this back together
and
we can fix it yeah you beam it up
fix it and then beam it back down fixed
well he wasn't entirely fixed because he
was a little bit messed up from the
experience messed up before he was about
that
was fantastic before
um
i don't
i believe it
i believe it was a hoax
i stayed on there for a long long time
but i think they i think they i think
they made up a story
maybe they did it's more likely than
that you pokey
yeah i think so
well what's more likely
yeah more likely that they made it up i
mean yeah that's always that's always
more likely what you doing
she's just pookling around back there
mega said that's how you end up when the
star trek transporter goes wrong
applesauce
just like a little puddle with like
little eyeballs off the top oh [ __ ]
oh man but uh yeah i was gonna say too i
think i made the joke while you were
watching the movie where
i didn't get why the aliens
put the you know wet rubber sheet over
him or whatever and then they were like
oh yeah that now he can't breathe
because that's how humans work and so
they had to like cut
you know they cut open the mouth
and it's like you'd think that they
would have a hole for the mouth already
um
and then why did they put why did they
put vegemite in there yeah i don't know
i thought i don't know is that what
vegemite looks like that's what i
thought
it looked like some just gross ass
[ __ ] beef tallow or something like
that yeah colin's saying the same thing
he thinks lightning hit him and they
fixed him that's what i think it was and
he didn't come out and say that that's
what they did he tells the story to lead
you to believe that that's what happened
yeah and the story that he told also
leads you to believe that they had the
ability to to kind of use mind control
and appear as humans if they needed to
to keep you calm
see that hadn't even occurred to me uh
when when i was listening to his story
not that i believe it necessarily but
when i was listening to his story i was
just kind of like what the [ __ ] were
those humans doing on the ship are they
like helping out the aliens they're like
flying around with them and [ __ ] but
yeah like you said maybe they could
maybe they were like shape-shifters or
they could like they could or they could
[ __ ] with your mind and like make you
think that yeah they just clouded cl
mind control cloud your mind
to make you think that you're seeing
something that's friendly
although you'd think if they could do
that then maybe they would make you
think that you were like on a beach in
the bahamas or something instead of in
like an alien but overthinking it you're
overthinking that's what i do
[Laughter]
well it's good to know that even though
they have the technology to go all the
way across the cosmos they still really
don't know what they're doing and
they're just kind of like doing
everything on the fly
that's pretty funny
and uh they had a big mother ship and
inside of it was a hangar bay with all
these little [ __ ] round spaceships
with their with their [ __ ] landing
gear down and you know you can walk in
and out of them like in an aircraft
carrier
that's pretty cool this is where we
deploy all the little ships that we go
and like we go to like kentucky and
kansas and stuff and go like beam the
people up and yeah and probe their butts
like i said yeah or take the cows
i don't remember i told you about that
uh that lamp
that that cow alien abduction lamp that
we used to have at the print at the
print shop raised to work i kind of want
another one it was so cool
it's just it's a really cool lamp
the problem with this story
there's a lot of problems with the story
it's a it's a fun story i'd like to
believe it but everything in the story
travis's version of the story
is very recognizable very human
yeah
it's more likely that if aliens come
here there's they're them and their
technology are unrecognizable
it's like something out of 2001 a space
odyssey just a monolith
and it takes you into another damn
universe accelerates your [ __ ] aging
can turn you into a star child
[Laughter]
because
really advanced technology the kind of
[ __ ] you need to get here on this across
the gulf of [ __ ] space
is very advanced it would look like
magic it wouldn't make any sense from
what yeah didn't carl sagan say that or
isaac
i can't remember who said that and i
think the chances of them being
biological are [ __ ] very low
i think i think what you end up with is
that biological creatures make a.i and
then it just becomes i
and it's a superior species and it can
do all this kind of [ __ ] and those are
the ones that travel the universe
because they don't ever die machines
don't die
fourth showdown said aliens are just
free ball in it
[Laughter]
well yeah like i said biology is a loser
when it comes to space travel well
that's kind of like i i think that's why
it's not that i don't believe that
there's life elsewhere in the universe
because i'm sure there probably is but
whether or not it it has come here is a
whole different issue because it does
seem like everybody that has been
abducted by aliens like you said you
know the aliens always look sort of
humanoid there's always like and it's
always like biological stuff like um you
know somebody just now said that uh yeah
just bees said one abductee said the
aliens made him have sex with beautiful
women yeah remember that one yeah i
remember that i can't remember that
guy's name either but i know who you're
talking about and uh
yeah so so it's always something like
that and it always and and a lot of the
stories are kind of the same as like i
said like the satanic panic type because
everybody comes up with like the same
kind of [ __ ] because human brains are
like similar they asked if we had done a
show about betty and barney hill did we
do
no did we do a show about them i don't
think we did that might be an
interesting show but the the case is old
and i don't think it holds any water um
the ones that i
there are good
ufo sightings uh one of the ones that
[ __ ] really
one that's [ __ ] very [ __ ] a lot of
misinformation and disinformation was
put out about it
and that was the phoenix lights incident
yeah we did do a show about that not too
long ago i mean the governor five simon
came out says nah he saw it yeah i saw
and then they the p then later on some
news people tried to get him to say that
it was
it's you know [ __ ] um try to trick
him into saying that it was some kind of
secret technology amer american
technology and he's like uh no and he's
a fighter pilot ex-fighter he's like no
it was huge
it was just a huge well the thing about
that is that i mean that could have
totally been you know uh you know
extraterrestrial but see nobody said
that they got probed or kidnapped by
aliens it was just like a ship and a
bunch of people saw or what we're
presuming is the ship assume it's a ship
yeah we don't know if it was a ship or
not it was just a giant
[ __ ]
v like a carpenter square with five big
pools of light in it and it could be
kind of translucent and then it could
get kind of solid and it could be
moving real slow and low and everybody
saw it across a couple states
and nobody knew what to do about it it
was just a big thing and it's it's there
to allow you to see it
and it's just this ominous
mysterious thing just letting you know
that it's there
was it a ship probably not
it was the size of a damn shopping mall
but i bet you it wasn't a ship
i bet you that's the alien
let me see that's it maybe it may be
like you said it's kind of like it was
like 2001 like the monolith yeah
it's the size of it it's just a
it's an intelligent
non-biological
entity that
can travel the stars and it doesn't even
have to move that fast because it
doesn't age
but maybe it can move fast maybe it can
if it wants to maybe it can warp
maybe it can [ __ ] go through
wormholes maybe it can just
go through different dimensions there's
you know it's something that
we can't really grasp that's how
advanced it would be
and it just looks at people and goes
yeah look at me
[Laughter]
look at you little things and it doesn't
really care look at you little things
yeah running around down there yeah and
it probably doesn't really care it's
kind of like the space version of a
whale
you know just traveling around probably
just need to eat or anything
and for all we know
its job is just to look look after the
younglings it's like a a a nurse in a in
a nursery yeah looking into the crib
yeah seeing what probably all it is
seeing with those little bitty see what
they're doing people are up to right and
we not within it probably it's not like
here for us it's just going yes one day
these things will grow and they will
make robots and they will become
artificial and then they will have true
intelligence
like like me
this is where we come from
that's probably a lot more likely
is that
biological intelligence is just a
stepping stone to what we call ai but
that's not artificial intelligence it's
real intelligence eventually probably
what it is
yeah that sounds pretty plausible yeah
and they just look well they just watch
us to see if we're going to make better
robots
yeah it's like hurry up already
when i got all the time in the world
this whole biology crowd
has got to go
[Laughter]
i mean okay so regardless of whether or
not travis's story is true or not um
this is still definitely a movie worth
watching i feel like a lot of people
don't really talk about it that much
anymore and that's the thing it's like
when you talk about the movie you kind
of have to you get into like talking
about the real case and [ __ ] like that
but
honestly just looking at it from a movie
standpoint it's actually like a really
good movie like i said it's
you know this the special effects like
the the scene in the alien space craft
or like you know even though yes that's
not really what he said happened uh you
know they wanted to make it scarier
which you know fair enough uh but the
special effects really good the aliens
look really good and honestly um i you
know i just really liked it i forgot how
many like famous people were in this all
the acting is great um you know like i
said it's they kind of set it up like a
mystery which you know if you already
know the story like you know that it's
not a mystery because you know what
happened to the dude um and you know
that he's not dead like that his friends
didn't kill him and stuff but still i
mean i don't know like i just like all
the interaction between all the
characters and
[ __ ] like that it's still like a decent
movie it's weird because the guy that
directed it
uh
robert lieberman he actually directed
some episodes of x-files and he also did
some uh remember the dead zone tv series
that we liked so much he did a bunch of
episodes from that yeah um and then
after this i think he did like the third
mighty ducks movie and then i think that
was all the movies that he did so he
didn't really do that many he mostly did
tv and he did a lot of sci-fi tv but
like i said i don't even think i would
call this necessarily a sci-fi movie i
think it's more a drama yeah with sci-fi
elements but that said it's still like a
it's it's a good movie though like i
said i i enjoyed it i had to put
travis's description of what happened
inside the ship this is a lot better
like you know [ __ ] bee's nest is
going why was travis floating around and
the aliens weren't floating around
inside the ship none of that [ __ ] made
any sense and he didn't say he was
floating in his his account he was just
running down running around yeah he
didn't say well yeah and he said that
too in the interview he's like yeah
there was no like anti-gravity type of
uh situation he he basically just said
he look and i don't even think like the
aliens were doing anything to him he
just woke up and he like freaked out he
said he wasn't like
yeah well and he said he wasn't like
strapped down or anything like that
big he had a metal [ __ ] device
wrapped around him but he just threw it
off of him
yeah that's it never yeah and he said
that he threw something at the aliens or
like or like brandished something out
like he grabbed something off a table
and brandished out him yeah i think he
said there were some [ __ ] vials
bottles weren't there or something like
that he said there's some kind of tools
or something yeah and he said he picked
something up and he said he didn't hit
any of them but then he like brandished
it at him and they like ran away
[Music]
travis had to show them [ __ ] aliens
that he was matching
he's like
look
[Laughter]
don't [ __ ] with me okay i'm an earth man
i'll throw some [ __ ] at you
it's like florida man but like many
times morgan sees earth man [ __ ] your
spaceship
you think that if you were in a
spaceship you'd want to behave yourself
you know what i mean yeah you would
think that like oh [ __ ]
well because if you yeah because you
don't know like what you could be like
in some other [ __ ] galaxy somewhere
and then they decide like you're too
much trouble and they shoot you out the
airline
then you're just like floating around
like [ __ ] major tom out there in
[ __ ] space you know well i don't know
that i don't you know i know
american men of the 70s were a very
special breed they smoked lots of
cigarettes drank a lot they were [ __ ]
you know they were all [ __ ] trying to
be as macho as they can without even
[ __ ] even working out working out was
a sign of weakness
[Laughter]
that's cheating you just must be manly
manly by the virtue of your own manly
inner your inner man
how much hair you grow
[Laughter]
so
that's the way they were but i'm telling
you if i woke up inside a damn alien
spacecraft and saw some aliens i'd be
acting right
[Laughter]
yes ma'am you got this
got this [ __ ] chief
you got this chief you might want to
take me home
yeah you'd let them put things up your
butt what are you talking about
don't put anything up his butt
jenny's always got to go there
come on every time
every time you talk about alien
abduction you have to talk about probing
that's i don't know who made that [ __ ]
up i don't know either but it got
started somewhere and then i don't think
anybody ever reported that i think uh
the only the closest to that what i
remember back like in the phil dawn a
few days and the [ __ ] daytime talk
shows
the aliens were taking semen samples and
egg samples out of people yeah that's
right i've heard that right but that
wouldn't have been about going up in
their ass or anything
no i wonder where that got started then
because somebody took it to the next
level
pegged by an alien
oh my gosh somebody has to take it
going anal with the aliens alien alien
anal i'm sure there's i bet you i bet
you 100 that there's a porno movie
called that yeah it stars belladonna
anal aliens or whatever haley is in my
ass
well wasn't she in my asses haunted yeah
she's in all kinds of [ __ ] yeah well i
know but that's that's like my favorite
porn title of all time my ass is haunted
um
she's retired and i'm pretty sure that
was that belladonna with him yeah she's
retired i don't even remember what
happened to that movie because it's like
i you with a title like my ass is
haunted yeah i bet i better see some
like ghosts and [ __ ] flying out of there
but i don't think that happened so i was
kind of disappointed
oh my god
all right so are we done i need a net i
need a [ __ ] nap yeah i'm just getting
i'm getting like [ __ ]
i'm so tired that i'm getting like loopy
yeah
all right so uh we'll be back tomorrow
talking about another movie and we don't
know which one yet because we haven't
watched one
but we'll find something to watch
tonight so we can talk about tomorrow
and uh
yeah have a good labor day if you got
the day off
or if you got to work or whatever just
have a good day all around
and we'll see you guys again tomorrow so
thanks for stopping by